hey Don O'Brien here like all Americans
I love apps I filled my phone with apps
and today I'm looking mostly at
stress-relieving apps because I have a
stressful job I'm gonna review these
stress-relieving apps and tell you which
ones to get which ones not to the lap
was unnecessary okay this first app is
called stress remover you'll see the
little icon it looks like a tiny
Anderson Cooper which is a good start
because I find him to be very calming
and says choose an image and here we go
here is my producer Jordan shlonsky so
it shows him choose attack method that's
interesting it's not very soothing I
will say knife touching it oh and a
knife just went into is I don't underst
oh I see I hate Jordan which I do and
I'm shooting knives into him okay now it
just looks like a Manson family
Christmas tree I don't think that was a
stress reliever it fueled my anger
towards Jordan and it just makes me want
to stab him in the face in real life
stress-free this is nice
hi I'm Andrew Johnson this program is
designed to guide you into a deep
natural state of relaxation
why is Sean Connery talking to me in the
afterlife so let's focus now and
different parts of your body become a
wit of your forehead forehead why is a
Scottish man talking during this it was
fine without you
relax nope not a relaxing voice relax no
I'm not going to all right I'm gonna
move on to massage loading bushi wait oh
headaches went away I got so transfixed
by her let me go back hold on what
happened what did I do now farm heroes
no I don't want farm heroes I don't know
what I did
where is the girl she's waiting for me
she loves me okay get away get away I'm
with her now I want Swedish what's
supposed to happen it's supposed to by
brain I can do with my phone
watch what did you just put it on
vibrate yeah get away from me
oh I know this app is used to be they
changed the name used to call blue balls
no Barney Rose this is called cracks and
breaks okay I guess I'll choose the
fluorescent lights that's it this is
pissing me off
let's find something we can break for
real find me something we can break for
real I'm gonna compare breaking these
light bulbs with breaking a real light
bulb here's the problem with this app
you break these light bulbs it's not
satisfying you go out and you get a real
light bulb you find out you can't break
it because you're throwing it into a
plastic bucket and then you get really
angry
this is you gave me a non-breaking light
bulb this design here I got another
light bulb the hell what happened to
light bulb just put it in here just
smash it with this Oh God okay you did
it did it
[Music]
all right we just looked at a bunch of
relaxing apps I think my heart right now
is about 165 and I've never been this
angry in my life which if you knew me is
really saying something so good job I
guess to you who found these apps I've
found them
you found them okay did you hear they
were good I mean they were rated high
I'm talking to a guy holding a plastic
trash can that's why I'm getting my
advice from you're a tech hobo out you
go run along now